let's get into our first segment here
what's hot and fraud this is where we
warn our listeners about popping scams
in the zeitgeist and more often than not
we get a letter from you guys out there
as always snitch on your friends and
family at scam gotta spot it gmail.com
just make sure your scam is retired
because we don't wanna what yes [ __ ] up
your bag amen
miranda nathan i need a fake name for
this person we don't care about gender
could be anything
mary ellen
how classy
i love that because it's so old and
timey that it's gonna fit perfectly into
this episode
mary ellen oh mary ellen when you have a
baby named mary can you call him mary
like when they say an adult me
well all baby names become adult names i
know but certain yeah you're not a very
child like they're just meant to be for
an adult yeah
if your name is kiki when you become an
adult you're gonna have to try to find
something more adult than that like
right
you're like no your name is kiki on the
birth certificate no no i'm 25 now
that's katherine we just we're changing
the name we can't be kiki anymore um
it's like a lot of family members of
mine have little in front of their names
still like we call them like on the
people daryl and they're grown adults
and we're like yeah this little daryl
what name would have you picked nathan
maybe yours would be better well see i
was going to go eve i was going to go
brune hilda
so which is like fart that gives me like
django unchained but it's like a german
name
hilda
you can decide blazie which which name
is the winner mary ellen or brumilda um
they're both pretty great maybe i give
them four names so marilyn brumhilde
[Laughter]
says i think you're 10 out of 10 and the
most delightful the scam i have to share
is one that i caught off one of my first
graders doing i'm a teacher shout out to
the teachers really shout out to y'all
man like
who i don't know how y'all do it no i'm
not dealing with nobody's unemployed
spawn all day
and then they mouthy they got attitude
and lip and it's like you don't pay no
bills
how dare you i literally had to tell my
four-year-old that the other day
he's like
yep you can slam the door when it's your
house you ain't panel doorbells in here
right you ain't got no wd-40 money
you're not gonna send the repair man out
for that crack in that door that you
made
that's right
those four-year-olds need to know they
do i love that that's your version of
like what black people call mcdonald's
money like when we were kids like we'd
always want to go to mcdonald's i don't
know why this is a universal black
experience we were like let's go to
mcdonald's and then our parents would be
like you got mcdonald's money
of course i don't
i'm unemployed
but i love them being like you guys you
got door slamming money
i don't think you do so that's a solid
core door child right these doors are
expensive what you're doing i love that
so much so uh mary ellen bermilda says
in my class
my students earn tickets in various ways
so you've got to [ __ ] compensate
these children like well i gotta pay you
for a free edition like for bad behavior
or
when i was little i had to pull my card
did you ever do that yes and it's like
getting a ticket
kind of i mean you have to pull the card
and then eventually it gets to red yeah
and then you're done oh yeah you might
as well just that goose is give up it's
over you know what they didn't factor in
like children who were like meant to be
entertainers or people who were not like
like okay we had something at our
elementary school called self managers
and self managers got these gold badges
that they could wear around and they
would have like little pizza parties
like every quarter and i always wanted
to be a self manager but you had to have
good grades and you couldn't get your
card pulled a lot so i would have good
grades but i'll be getting my card
pulled all the time because i'll be
talking cash [ __ ] in class
and for some reason at this school and
we all wear uniforms there were a lot of
russian kids and all the russian kids
were self-managers
[Music]
a government who
[Laughter]
i don't know but they were all self
managers and i was always so envy of
this i'm like man oh you got she is so
managing how did you become one how did
you like what did you have to do to get
it be quiet and get good grades and i
could get good grades but i couldn't be
quiet
like a self manager would need to have
confidence and be loud yeah right i
manage it myself
right exactly showing leadership
qualities
exactly marielle and broomhilda is
giving out these tickets positive
reinforcement miranda
they write their names on them and at
the end of the day we do a drawing with
those tickets we always choose two names
and those two students get to choose a
prize from my prize box
man i miss being a kid cause we should
be delighted by the most basic ass [ __ ]
like a [ __ ] eraser that smelled good
i'm like oh
a pencil but it's got cinnamon on it
when are we gonna get our mesothelioma
commercial which i think is gonna be
like if you were a loved one who smells
a magic sniff marker you may be entitled
to damages i know some that was doing
something to us for sure and i was
sniffing them all i love the grape one
ah the best why do you need to sniff a
pen or a marker like that's insane you
can't sniff any of the other markers so
wait why are there only certain markers
you can't sniff honestly a gateway drug
because then you know i started sniffing
um
permanent markers then you get a little
out yeah then you get the white out
you know
it's a slippery slope just the paint
huffing that's that's the gateway
magic markers for children so they get
something from the prize box last week i
noticed one student had been winning an
uncanny amount of times like homie was
getting a prize eight out of nine days
in a row and i should have caught it
earlier but i've been having health
issues and it's the end of the year and
you know how it goes i know absolutely
how it goes and also you a teacher you
got to be out here being a
you got to be a teacher you got to be
like martial law you gotta it's just
it's an insane position that this
country has put our educators in and
they don't pay them well enough i'm like
i'm glad y'all not in here shaking the
kids and
pinching them under there
i be pitching all the kids
[Laughter]
so shout out to you so anyway she's like
i didn't notice that this was happening
anyways i investigated a little bit and
noticed that on the tickets that had his
student that had this student's name you
could faintly see an erased name
underneath it
i asked the student about it and they
were like every day when you put my
ticket in the jar i would take a few
tickets out and erase whoever's name was
on it and then write my own
he just gave himself up it's like he was
so proud like you know in movies when
the villain just starts talking for a
long time about what they did
and you're wondering like why is that
villain talking for 15 minutes
but think about it if he only took a few
out and left some his eyes are still
pretty good
this teacher must not been shaking up
the ticket mode he was just sprinkling
him on top was my teacher impressed
what did the teacher do he says honestly
for a first grader this is the
equivalent of ocean's 11 heist because
they are just very bad liars and never
sneaky so props to this kid but i did
have to remove all the tickets that had
their name on it in the jars so they
couldn't keep winning prizes
so basically what he was doing was
stacking the deck because like they get
these tickets for being good and then
the tickets accumulate
so he was doing something evil but he
was getting the tickets for being good
because she thought he was being good
and then he was also writing his name on
all that little by little every day he
was stacking the deck because he's
adding more tickets every single time
because he's erasing people's names so
think of like a big jar and then every
time you get good tickets right she
reaches into the same jar and you have
better chances of winning if you're
better behaved i'm just trying to figure
out what you need when is he getting
them back into the jar because he's got
to take him out he's got to take him
away he's got to go erase them put his
name back on it these kids are fine in
that time there was a viral tweet about
a teacher that she was like i took a
phone away from a child in my class and
then i turned around and she had the
phone again and she was on it and she
was like how did you get this phone and
she was like oh you and my mama love a
little drawer and like went back to her
phone
y'all love a little drawer chat i just
went in the door i got it
just open the drawer
i love that though i love when kids are
criminals i love it because you can tell
early on if a kid is going to be a
criminal a few ways you can tell if they
open up a lemonade stand i had a
lemonade stand
multiple times as a child you're just a
scam waiting to happen
taking time i have a good lemonade stand
what child model money isn't what people
think it is
i should have an open your small
business after your child my little
career
so we got a pivot now i'm a child model
who sells lemonade on the street corner
no what kind of lemonade were you
slanging my mom helped me make it it was
homemade lemonade which nowadays i feel
like nobody would buy right they would
be scared to get noted man the good old
days when you could leave your doors
unlocked and buy unmarked lemonade on
the street i remember how excited i was
because um my cross street neighbor they
were doing construction and i knew all
the construction workers were going to
be there one day oh
[Music]
you are a scammer of already like oh and
today is hot 89 degrees oh yeah y'all
gonna be parked put up a little easy up
right over there so they could stand in
line in the shade and get their ice cold
lemonade put out the catalog that i had
the picture in from the child modeling
to draw on it actually that's creepy
yeah i don't know
not totally sure about that part
it was
i love it i love it i think you could
put out a sign that's like a struggling
former child
that would have been good please buy
lemon sugar water help a struggling
child model